[Musique]
ce sont les premiers ateliers citoyen
participatif sur le plan de transition
écologique et solidaire du département
des ateliers d'échangés de débats qui
donne la parole aux réunionnais autour
de différentes thématiques comment on
peut recycler pour l'empreinte carbone
qui sont moins importantes
qu'est-ce qu'on peut mettre en place
pour réduire ces modes de transport sans
réduire la consommation de l'enseignant
de transport au sens large au niveau de
l'environnement que ce soit
l'agriculture consommer localement ou
aussi au niveau de la végétalisation
autant de questionnements et d'apports
d'idées qui vont porter cette
concertation citoyenne et permettre
d'élaborer un plan de transition
écologique et solidaire
construit sur les problématiques de
notre société
enrichir le plan avec les idées laser de
ce qu'on appelle les experts d'usagé
c'est-à-dire ceux qui sont vraiment
habituée à traiter tout ce qui est sûr
là sans fin sans forcément penser qu'ils
sont écolos ou faire voter que sans
qu'ils soient forcément dans une
démarche de transition
les premiers participants ont pu
débattre ce matin au jardin de l'état et
proposer les premières pistes d'actions
qu'il faut obligatoirement autour de la
table met les acteurs compétents que sur
l'état la région et les autres
collectivités pour arriver à un
consensus commun sur des méthodes de
déplacement qui qui permettra de
de mieux vivre demain quoi que en fait
ce qui pollue aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
jette c'est clair un deux roues que ce
que le propose aujourd'hui c'est de ne
plus jeter mais de valoriser
il est possible de participer à cette
concertation citoyenne sur la transition
écologique et solidaire du département
du 16 octobre au 16 novembre ou sur
internet au www.desjardins.com point fr
rubrique je participe
[Musique]